the Joe Rogan experience I mean who has
the ultimate influence in whether or not
there is military action and how long
that military action goes on for right
like cuz Bernie Sanders and a lot of
these people and Tulsi Gabbard a lot of
people that are running for president
say that if they got one of the things
they would do is to stop these
interventional interventionalist Foreign
Wars and this world police wars that we
just go on and invading other people's
lives that we would stop doing that I
think that's great right but who really
gets to say like who gets to say whether
or not war like who talks to Trump and
says let's just keep rolling into this
place
what's wrong there's a [ __ ] problem
over there Isis Isis building up what
bomb [ __ ] guys people like who has the
real ear I mean is it is it generals I
mean does is there any industry
influence at all from weapons industries
or from people who have deals with them
or you know that's what Eisenhower
warned about when he left office you've
heard that right yeah that is one of the
craziest speeches a president has ever
said Trump says you do have a
military-industrial complex they do like
war yeah well they say you try to pull
some troops out and they wouldn't let
him oh that's right Trump said that
don't kid yourself he says you do have a
military-industrial complex they do like
war you know in Syria with the Caliphate
so I wipe out 100% of the Caliphate that
doesn't mean you're not going to have
these crazy people going around blowing
up stores and blowing up things these
are seriously ill people but I wiped out
a hundred percent of the Caliphate I
said I want to bring our troops back
home the place went crazy they want to
keep you have a problem here in
Washington they never want to leave I
said you know what I'll do I'll leave a
couple hundred soldiers behind but if it
was up to them they'd bring thousands of
soldiers in someday people explain it
but you do have a group and they call it
the military-industrial complex they
never want to leave they always want to
fight no I didn't want to fight but you
do have situations like Iran you can't
let
them have nuclear weapons you just can't
let that happen that goes on like and
that's you know that's one of the thing
with Trump nobody ever talks about I
feel like is it's like we've been pretty
much anti you know we haven't been
swayed into as many Wars as I feel like
we would have been who knows I mean who
knows me maybe yes maybe no maybe we're
closer to war because of him who the
[ __ ] knows Trump administration
considers 14,000 more troops for the
Middle East last week hmm
but he also suggesting deployment you
know who knows men
maybe they know things too you know the
thing about talking to people like
jockle will Inc and you know my friend
Andy stump and other other folks that
have been over there like they'll
they'll tell you there's there's some
times where things build up and radicals
control cities and things get really
ugly and then they have to have some
sort of military intervention or these
people to keep growing and they you know
they dump that's the other thing that
people aren't talking about like in
Afghanistan in particular the afghan e's
are working with the soldiers against
these terrorist organizations like
there's afghan ease that are helping US
soldiers is not like all of the u.s.
against all of afghanistan no it's that
they're combined against isis the assist
the whole thing is so crazy that there's
these groups these organizations that
are like characters in a James Bond
movie or in a comic book
right like think about like Isis like
some similar guy says that's like if you
had a crazy movie about people that you
know had a great leader who's like a
spiritual guy lived in the mountains and
you know what that sauce AMA bin Laden I
mean he is like a character in a movie
used to work for the for the good guys
then he switched over to the bad guys
it's like someone in a Batman movie
right you know yeah lips and caves yeah
it's just all of it is weird man oh I
mean it's a whole thing about you draw
Mohammed they'll kill you like how
extreme
religion is and how devoted people are
and you can't question any of it
it's the most extreme in that regard
where it doesn't doesn't allow any
questioning of it and then you know
people can't understand that some people
practice it the same way some people
practice Christianity or some people
practice other things they only they
only believe or take part in the
positive good parts of the religion so
there's a lot of people that are Muslims
that are great people they're really
kind really well educated wonderful
thoughtful people they don't have
nothing to do with terrorists and when
there is some sort of terrorist activity
it makes them feel bad that they're
getting lumped in with someone who's
doing horrific things these people that
you know end up committing to these
extreme religions that gilligan we
should be dropping like soccer balls and
intend Oh switches from airplanes to
give them things to do so they're well
they're stuck believe in something if
you're stuck in a place that it's got a
very rigid religious ideology and
radical and you know you've been
radicalized since you were young and
then you got places like Yemen right
places that are getting bombed by the
u.s. from [ __ ] robots planes are
flying overhead they're gunning down
wedding parties accidentally and killing
people I mean that happens it's pretty
common right so you're making more
radicals because then there's people who
lost their family members to some robot
flying in the sky that some kid is I you
know he's got an xbox control on his
hand he's shooting missiles you know
they say those guys who are those pilots
they suffer PTSD as well those pilots
are weirded out by that [ __ ] you know
imagine being a drone pilot and you're
watching something that you kind of know
is happening
you definitely know what's happening
right you're controlling it you see it
but when you hit that button you watch
those missiles choo choo choo choo choo
shoot down Hellfire missiles to comb
Hellfire too which is crazy
shoot shoot down into these camps shoot
down into these uh motorcades like you
know what you just did and most likely
you're killing eight out of ten of those
people are innocent and because of the
fact that a drone does it we're like
yeah we gonna do like we had a soldier
and like hey Tony you've got a
stop killing innocent people hey I'm a
[ __ ] killer okay you sent me after
those bad guys there's a lot of babies
around
I had a [ __ ] let him know you ain't
gonna stop me from getting that bad guy
there's no way we put you in jail yeah
but if you have an Xbox controller and
you're shooting Hellfire missiles into a
[ __ ] school because you think that
there's a terrorist in there like what
and you know they set them up sometimes
too they give bad advice or bad Intel
yeah so they try to get someone to blow
up a school or get someone to blow up a
wedding party like there's a lot of
[ __ ] involved in anything you're
doing like that where they know that if
you do kill people it's actually bad
press it's bad for you
public public perception goes the other
way
[Applause]